are you uh are you a keyboard
and because you're just my type
Harry are you
reasonably hairy white quite furry
sorry I'm making you embarrassing I
could ask the same with you I mean yeah
I mean I am yeah very very uh no I
oh that's good to me you were lost it's
lovely to meet you it's very nice to be
here I feel like I've been misled by the
name of the show slightly I've been here
a minute and no one's done anything
remotely loose
hello
[Applause]
High Caliber people like Robert and Don
Cheadle it's like the rush of working
with actors like that is the same as if
we're do on you know an Off-Broadway
play so it doesn't matter really that
it's
a big pop culture movie you know because
you're not doing it with like some 26
year old shirtless guy who doesn't
really have a lot to say you know it's
like you're doing a Robert Downey Jr so
it is artistically fulfilling I mean I
think that's the way we've sort of by
the way him without a shirt is awesome
don't get me wrong uh 22 years ago no
right now and he is the best butt in the
world I recommend you touching it on the
way out great idea
um how would you rate yourself on a
scale of one to ten in the bedroom
um be honest I'm gonna say eight point
something right okay everybody can get
better I'm humble you know I can get
better right it depends also how much
you've had to drink you know what kind
of if it's morning afternoon depends on
the woman uh-huh it depends how many
women
that's why a lot of treadmill a lot of
treadmill yeah yeah yeah you better go
on the treadmill you've got a yeah
you've got a very big reputation that
you need to hold up to and by big
reputation I'd be massive peanuts
foreign
I just want to know do you treat
everybody like this or are we special
puth are we because we felt something in
that last interview you want the media
train answer no not the real answer you
want the real answer y'all are hot
I'm sorry use that for the promo people
no no you're like really pretty and I
get like uh I I get uh this is like the
more boyish like calm down don't anger
my publicist answer it's like I get
Larry flushed around like such beautiful
women and I do like this vibrant uh
springy colors like I can't even look at
this I can't even look I'm getting over
I'm getting off these big greens right
here it's too early for this right now
what's going on never too early do you
like my jacket uh yeah real quick
do I have your consent to feeling yeah
it feels cool right yeah
yeah that's because it's made of
boyfriend material
oh wow wow oh whoa oh
you look wait a minute
new hair dude
I like your hair I'm glad you you always
notice my hair I do know that it's the
first thing about you that I noticed it
yeah actually you're falling out of your
dress
thank you Jay how are they doing
listen end of the day this is what makes
me baby
end of the day this is what makes no no
you got different types of men you got
soldiers and you got tanks
I'm the one that's shooting the bullet
you understand what I'm saying so
basically you know to get to what I got
you gotta think about a squirrel if he
goes up a tree what happens you Dad
gonna write Peter Pan Is Gonna Come
really yeah wow
she was into you I think it wasn't an
app
I think she was playing the game with me
not like not like you ladies are into me
or anything like that like that could
ever work out I think maybe one day
how many times do I have to come on this
show and just we need to do once a week
okay
after all you've done in your career and
in your life is there anything still
left on your bucket list just you
wow it's all done now
I don't know what to say tonight
just to own it
I like this eye contact bad and pouty
you'll never be sad and probably with
you sitting there oh
oh my
God okay let's see how many years
Millions if that's the case no she says
she says even though I'm Spanish you
know I like that chocolate oh
but does that work no and I tell her
once you go check you never go back
I don't think Morgan Freeman will have a
snake cup at his house
oh really maybe he already has one maybe
give him one as a gift by one of his
friends
you're gonna give me a snake I'll give
you a snake cup young lady yeah
not dirty I said I'd give you a snake
dope and you will receive one and you
will enjoy it
because like when he's off camera like
he's just like watching dumb videos like
gym accidents you know fart jokes like
so chill hilarious yeah um ask him who
makes his [ __ ] pop all right
who does don't even say it's from us
just ask him as if it's your question
what makes my [ __ ] pop
ah God and every time she goes oh uh
that makes my [ __ ] pop whatever it
means to make your [ __ ] pop
um
yeah I love that girl she is Bonkers
it's true it's true
oh my God
what does that mean she's like I don't
know what it is but it sounds good yeah
I don't know but I love it
okay thank you okay let's get to the
point
um
what were you like in high school I was
a nerd like kind of like I am now but
I'm just a bit cockier now
um
well I guess I I had big puffy hair I I
stayed up all night like producing music
and playing the piano though producing
music like I always went for the guys
who played music oh well it sounds like
I have it sounds like I was born in the
wrong year ladies and gentlemen first
thing you do when you wake up first
thing I do when I wake up I say hey you
all right
[Laughter]
say what you do who are you interviewing
today
oh you're interviewing me all right I'll
be right behind you I'm just playing
America
uh poof did you have fun today you're
leaving here today feeling what
um I I like like something dirty I don't
know
oh something cute are you a good um
horseback rider
bareback I'm really good at riding on
the back of men's horses
I'm actually mean for that to be dirty
it just came out that way so sorry no
you did mean it to be good
and that's okay I'm feeling feisty
because I'm extremely messed up right
now
I'm happy for you
what is in that cup
something
juice
what
yeah you can have a drink of it good put
your hands on the snake and then drink
up this is the side you drink out of
right that's to say don't drink out of
it
you can have another drink if you want
[Applause]
because because now it's like you and I
Have Kissed before you even have the
chance to kiss Morgan Freeman only if I
drank out of it then would we have
kissed drink out of it just do it you
gotta do that side yeah there you go
laughs
okay